does it only wonder how to stab and
articulating what is the difference
between a wage and salary you
like teachers they yeah fantastic
okay so this is worth trying down
through so important how the rate is
exactly what I said
okay and most people they're for your
age you're gonna get wages right it's
like a white iron by I've worked with
other houses with so they're gonna pay
me 11 times whatever my hourly rate is
and then it might include penetrates it
so what that means is wages tend to get
paid to certain kinds of workers namely
casual or part-time stuff like casual or
part-time it's like I work a different
number of hours every single week so
sometimes I'll get this amount of money
casual part-time people they're gonna
get that if however you've got
somebody's not casual or part-time
someone who's full-time they're like a
permanent member of staff that means
approval getting the same about every
single week maybe they mean if it isn't
isn't it so that's where salaries come
salaries are pretty much an annual about
okay so someone say I'll ever and this
and thinking they refer to me is how
much in a whole year than anything so
wages are an hourly rate they're
generally for casual part I'm sorry
casual or part-time style where salaries
are in annual amounts okay now I will
mention you can still have a part-time
worker if they're permanent they'll
still get a salary but it's what we call
provide does anyone not provide a means
whatever who's heard the phrase before
piranha
cool I'm gonna tell you something here
if you're pro rata it's for example
suppose you have here at school we have
loads of babies someone who worked two
days a week instead of full-time work
which is five days right
this person who works two days a week
and say me it works five is we we might
actually have the same salary the same
salary but because I work so much one of
them obviously I'm gonna
two days out of five what percentage is
two days out of fun that's 40% isn't
because each day is 20% once you get to
100
so therefore this person is going to get
40 percent of the salary right we still
have the same salary but they're only
earning
40% this is called privada cos like a
great right so it's like 40% of whatever
salary was it right so we might be
qualified at the same level with my true
statement of work but it's just a
function of how much time okay another
example of pro rata work is contracting
it's in to know when a contractor this
the name oldest telogen yeah someone
who's here to contract it's like hey for
example my brother he's an IT contract
right so his work but a company never
really once and I take contractor for
more than like six months left I'm like
that's a long job thank you good work on
that project
okay so he's gonna do exactly the same
thing because he's got six months on the
job right six months at all twelve so
pro rata what rate is he gonna get
it's just gonna get hard for you to
percent we might have the same salary
right we might be doing the same work
and so on but here let me get that
saying that because he works for shorter
man okay
so that's all that's referring to you'll
see that word sometimes come up any
questions or anything so getting this
distinguishment distinction between
these two and trying to get the student
married together that's mainly what this
exercises about right comparing okay if
I'm casual an item this one per hour
right a salary person almost always take
it and let's say how many how many days
do you think Saul works in a year do we
know this how many are how many days are
there any use there are three and six to
five but no one no one works for all of
those days right for example everyone
has 12 salary people are gonna have
weekends right so that's like every
seven days they lose - so maybe instead
of counting days we should count you
weeks right cuz every year the same
weeks so we're going to go with 52 weeks
now in Australia the award says you get
full weeks of annual leave every four
weeks it's not very much but that's all
in there so that means having what
working weeks are there are 48 rights
under your 48 working weeks
okay
who is that
each one's by dates right what is 48
times
200 and well 250 would be 50 times 5 so
I just got you back which is 240 so 240
working days now you should shut this
down this is an important number right
something interesting will happen and
you can counter this and the questions
that you gave if you take someone's
salary and you divide it by 2 for 30 40
okay / charity as an example what so you
might tell me it's not so private or
government employees so why I'm pretty
sure if you love it is that a lot okay
yeah it's worth mentioning and we'll get
more into this laid off this is from
coal-burning home so they having to take
a tax out of me I lose about half of
that attack so not as impressive as it
sounds but just going with that number
how would you like that in every single
day I'm just gonna divide our time okay
so if I go ahead and do
let's do sets as well
I'm getting this number okay so in
theory that's how much I'm getting paid
every day now I can tell you right now
for any of these kinds of situations of
is like provider empowering
someone's always going to be earning
more than me in every single day like a
casual stuff right if they qualify the
same as I am
they're going to be that any more than
that why is that why do the conent want
you to get salary why did they get
shafted and earn less than the casual
yep
yeah very good remember we kind of snuck
this in doing that are there were 52
weeks we get stuff like this we get out
of leaf right we also get stuff like
sickly we get all kinds of entitlements
all these things that get added in
because we're under this scheme here
right that's kind of like baked into
them if you're a contractor and you
start work you don't get paid like a
secret like I do
you just don't get paid then you don't
burn money that day right so it's kind
of a riskier way to work and that's why
to compensate don't give you a day so
that'll be per day that's me per day
okay but an equivalent person like who's
just at a casual rate might entertain
500 it's like a big deal that's a
complete jump okay but it's because it's
risk involved in that my brother like I
said he was a contractor because he
never gets to have like a whole years of
work and never said oh I can just wake
up in the morning now I know I'll have a
job there he gets paid substantially
more than me
of course of six months then I mean
twelve miles right because there's risk
penalty too strong
sometimes here's three months and it's
just
so there's always these things to
balance